all right we have a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two david p
this is funny we have very often heard
from a guy that I know as the san
antonio troll and one of the things that
he does frequently is call in and attack
me either for the position I took in a
story I didn't actually cover he'll say
David how dare you say XYZ and it's like
about a story I never even covered or he
likes to call in and say David you will
never ever cover this story because it
conflicts with this narrative or that
narrative that you're trying to
perpetuate in this case here is the san
antonio troll telling me i will never
ever ever cover the incident that took
place yesterday in jersey city of a
black a former black israelite shooting
up a kosher supermarket that story you
might remember was covered twenty
minutes ago
on today's program take a listen hey pac
man i know that you know ii you in your
show early in the morning on the
afternoon you put yourself on a bunch of
different medications that you got from
your psychiatrist you fall asleep rarely
at any of the news I know you probably
your face probably lit up when you saw
there's a shooting in New Jersey bad
news it wasn't a white person so leave
it alone don't touch the story doesn't
matter even if it were cues that were
the unfortunate victims but just don't
touch it saving you time man it wasn't a
white person so anyway that was weird I
don't know if that was like another
person in the background there was a
weird it's not kind of sound there of
course I did cover the story and
listened it this is not a program that
ignores stories because they don't fit a
particular narrative I do you know we
all have our biases I do the best I can
to always examine what the facts are and
to integrate those facts into my broader
assessment or position or worldview
I didn't ignore the story I covered that
story it was an anti-semitic incident we
talked about black Israelites we talked
about all of the different elements
surrounding this and sorry to disappoint
you san antonio troll but the story has
been covered already
on today's bonus show we will talk about
Nikki Haley's statement that the
Confederate flag could not be taken down
in South Carolina in today's outraged
culture what on earth is she talking
about we will talk about yet another one
of these instances where a big
corporation puts people's lives at risk
people actually die and then they pay a
tiny tiny fine to regulators or to the
government and there's really no
consequences that actually seem like
they would dissuade corporations from
engaging in the exact same type of
behavior again in this particular case
we're going to talk about Boeing on the
bonus show and the 737 max and then also
there is a lawsuit which claims that SAT
and ACT scores Act tests a CT tests are
illegal in California admissions why I
will tell you on the bonus show two ways
to get instant access become a member at
join pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show